There's quite a lot of difference,
but also a lot of similarities
between an architect
and an interior designer.
And today, I want to talk about
how each profession develops the concept.
And I wanted to talk about the concept
because it's really the foundation
of every design project and it's something
that informs every aspect of the design.
And fundamentally, it's how we approach
problems and come up with solutions.
I'll be talking about the difference
in how we approach problems.
I'll also be talking
about the hierarchy of importance
for each profession and how this can lead
to very different results.
A portion of this video is sponsored
by Sound Corps.
More on them later in this video.
Of course,
this is based on my personal observations.
I am an architect,
trained as an architect.
And I went through the traditional process
of becoming an architect.
But I did work in an interior design
slash architecture firm
where I was the only architect working
alongside other interior designers.
And this process was so interesting to me
and so eye opening.
And I actually saw a lot of flaws in my
own training and how I approach design.
So if you're an interior designer
watching this, please feel free to share
your thoughts and experiences
so that this comment section can become
a source of information
for young people who are trying to decide
which profession to go into.
I also have a discourse server
where you can ask questions
and we have a pretty big variety of people
from different professions and backgrounds
and experiences and skills.
So yeah, if you have any questions,
feel free to drop it in
there as well.
So high level architects
design the building and interior designers
design within that shell,
but there's also a lot of in-betweens
and a lot of architects
do interior renovations.
And personally I've worked on
a lot of interior renovations in my career
and really every project is unique
based on the client and the project type.
So keep that in mind
as you're watching this.
And if you want a full breakdown
of the differences
like of the project types
and the design process and the education,
as well as the skills and personality
that's required to thrive in each career.
Check out the video right here.
I think there's a lot of nuances
to the way we approach problems.
That's quite different
when it came to developing
the concept, and I really try
to distill it down to the essence.
I think the biggest difference
is that architects
derive their concepts
from external sources and
interior designers derive their sources
from internal sources.
Let me explain.
A concept is an idea
that becomes a foundation
and identity of every design project,
and it drives a forward.
It's the idea that informs
the different aspects of your building.
In every step of the design process
and whenever you're stuck,
you can refer back to the concept
to get some clarity in your direction.
It's also a really good way of embedding
meaning into the project
that's beyond just the building
or the space itself.
But most importantly,
it's a tool to get buy in from clients
and your team
and get everyone aligned on the same page.
Each office and each designer is unique
in their way of developing a concept.
So try to learn from others.
And as you work in different offices,
try to also develop
your own methods.
Architects tend
to derive their concepts
from external sources.
When you see an architect
presenting their work,
we typically start off
by describing the context
or the problems or opportunities
they see on the site or the program.
And this is all of your physical
or social constraints of your project.
And when you actually look at the most
convincing presenters like Bjarke Ingels,
they distill the problem
into a really clear series
of diagrams or images, and they use this
to develop their functional
or formal or material strategy,
which forms the basis for their concept.
But this isn't the case with just large
buildings, even one architecture
operating at a much smaller scale,
like interior renovations.
The way we present concepts
is almost always dependent
on an external or site specific
or program specific source.
Let me just pause for a quick moment
for a message from our sponsor, Soundcore.
I don't know about you guys,
but I feel like I'm constantly surrounded
by noise and distractions.
And for me, having a device
that can help me stay focused
really makes a difference.
Soundcore
Space A40 offers the perfect balance
between noise canceling performance,
sound quality and battery life.
As a creator, I always try to absorb
content as much as possible.
So listening to audiobooks
whenever I can
now is kind of a part of my daily routine.
The Space 840 Adaptive Noise Canceling
Feature automatically detects
different types of background noise
and improves word comprehension,
even at really high reading speeds.
The dedicated Soundcore app lets you
customize the noise canceling parameters
and and you can even create a tailored
sound experience via a sound ID,
which is a feature that generates an
IQ profile
based on your personal hearing biometrics.
It creates a really rich and vibrant
sound experience
that really makes me
want to listen to music even more.
Plus, these earbuds are really lightweight
and comfy to wear,
and they also have really useful magnets
that can keep them together
inside
or even outside of their charging box.
And with one single charge, you can get up
to 10 hours of playing time.
Check the link in the description
if you want to know more.
I'll give you an example with a project
that I'm working on right now,
which is a library renovation,
where the driving concept
is this idea of the urban courtyard.
This was from a series
of contextual factors.
The library has this really beautiful
garden that already kind of functions
as a central greenspace
in this very dense neighborhood.
And you can see this solid void
relationship within that building as well.
When you enter the building,
you've got this big three storey atrium
and the library is also
in a really diverse neighborhood.
It's got a really high percentage
of immigrants
and people
whose first language is not English.
The functional program of the library
is also pretty diverse.
We're putting in a digital media lab,
a lounge, a recording studio,
a grab and go section.
So we developed this idea of the urban
courtyard, and courtyards
have been pretty universal across
different cultures throughout history.
And although it first came to place
to control the micro climactic conditions
within buildings, over time it evolved
to become a social gathering place.
And so this shared architectural language
of the courtyard brings these diverse
cultures and programs together while
also bringing in an element of nature.
You can see how we developed the concept
by tying it
to some of these external conditions.
The broader and more flexible your concept
is, the better, because you can tie it
to a lot of different aspects
of the design, for example, the courtyard.
This can be functional or formal or social
or organizational,
and it has a lot of visual associations.
So it can be also used to develop
your material strategy.
But a concept like, let's say
a digital hub, which is an idea
that we've been talking a lot about.
It doesn't have a lot of historical
or architectural or visual
associations, so it's a little bit harder
to use it as a concept.
Even the most form driven architecture
like Frank Gehry's
work is in some way
relating to its context.
Now architects will take this,
and some architects
will create a mood board,
which I'll go into in a little bit.
But when it comes to the hierarchy
of importance for architects,
like based on our training
and our design philosophy, it's function,
organization, order, and then we have mood
for interior designers.
They don't really have these complex
conditions to work with, right?
So they derive a lot of their concept
ideas from internal sources.
And what I found
is that the concept development process
in interior
design is a lot more intimately
connected to the client
and their visions for the project.
And so during this phase,
we just sit with the client and we just
talk about their vision for the space,
not just programmatically or functionally,
but how they want the space to feel
and what's the image they want to project.
And the client, they can bring
their own inspiration images,
and if it's like a commercial client,
they can bring their own
brand and guidelines.
And we basically work with the client
to put together
visual representation of this feeling,
which is called a mood board.
But before doing this,
we would write a very small paragraph
or like a list of words or a poem
that kind of captures the mood or
the direction that we got from the client.
And I found this process
super interesting for me.
Language is not really my strong suit, so
this was definitely kind of hard for me.
But first of all, like, it's
a really, really great way to consolidate
all the information
that you got from the client.
But you're not just reciting
what the client is saying.
You're adding and you're elevating
all the things that they said
into a language
that have a visual connection.
So, for example,
we were designing an office
for a construction company,
and some of the words that they used
was things like trustworthy,
kind, family business.
And so you could use that to say something
like Grounded in family roots.
And this kind of descriptive writing.
It works hand-in-hand with the Moodboard,
which is basically a collection of images
that represent the mood or the feeling
that you're trying to create.
These images
aren't necessarily precedent images.
They're literally like images
that combine together to create a mood.
Everyone probably has
a slightly different way of doing it,
but the way that I was taught,
you shouldn't actually include
images of actual building elements.
That actually comes in a little bit later
in the design process.
I've seen a lot of different reactions
to this concept development process.
Some clients are a little bit
more literal and more pragmatic,
and they just want to quickly
move on to the actual design.
But for a lot of clients,
they get really involved
and they want to bring their own images.
And because interior design
is so much more based
on more elusive things
compared to architecture,
like they're more focused
on the mood of the space.
I think there's a much higher chance
of misalignment.
And so I think the step is a really,
really good check point.
And I think it's really essential
for everyone just to make sure
that we're all on the same page.
Once you have the mood board,
you pull together the colors
which become the basis
for your material board.
Each profession is really unique,
and each designer
and each office is really distinct
in how they operate.
As an architect, I learned so much
from that time when I was working with
interior designers,
and I think one of the most eye opening
things was the relationships
that they were building with the clients.
And maybe it's a result
of this more intimate process
where you talk
for prolonged periods of time
about the client's desires.
But I found that interior designers
in most cases
had a much more personal relationship
with their clients.
And I just thought
it was a really important element
that I could take into my work
as an architect.
I hope this video gave you
a little bit of insight
into the differences
and the nuances of each profession.
If you have any questions
or thoughts on the topic,
please let me know in the comments.
And if you guys found this video
hopeful, make sure to give me a thumbs up
and I will see you guys in the next video.